this headline should read father hates
evil regime who we are simultaneously
praising because we're pieces of [ __ ]
everyone's talking about North Korea at
the Olympics and the media reaction
which they should but it's just the what
about ISM so question of the day do you
really think because the left has drawn
this equivalence say do you really think
that in the United States is comfortable
in any way to evil empires of the past
or present and what do you make of the
blatant hypocrisy in the left fawning
over this performance sure than that
impressive in my opinion from North
Korea at the Olympics in comparison to
their outrage of this current
administration so this is the
performance in question from the North
Koreans where these cheerleaders I don't
know just a remarkable talents yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so the media is fawning over North Korea
at the Olympics you can even see do we
have some of these headlines we can
bring them up yeah do we have them the
headlines yeah there you go I love this
one from Cena Kim jong-un sister is
stealing the show at the Winter Olympics
by the way when she says she wants North
Korea and South Korea to come to come
together to fight she's talking about
under the family rule he's basically
saying we have Manik yeah but they don't
even know which way they want to go with
it so they're fawning over this
performance talking about how you know
what this can really bring us together
these kinds of events and they and they
was it really was they stole the show
with their synchronization we even if
that's the case you accept it as it's
only for one reason one hell motivation
and some funny enough because the left
was immediately called them all oh
really you're given this you're given
the okay to North Korea some like Abby
Martin on Twitter or claim that the
United States is actually worse than
North Korea so let's go through this and
this is what I think people are really
rubbed the wrong way because everything
is so outrageous here from Donald Trump
Africa comes for conservatives right the
safe space is the hate speech the [ __ ]
hat March can you believe it can you
Donald Trump is this tyrant and then
you're gonna give some leeway to North
Korea of all places really there should
be none zero why are you saying yes none
well but they're not Kim Jong I don't
care
anyone who anyone who wears the patch
that has anything to do with North Korea
no time for you notice that your you are
enemy number one so their claims let's
just compare some of their claims as to
what they think will happen under
tyrannical rule here in the United
States versus North Korea so claim of
course Donald Trump wants to remove
women's rights we've heard this this is
why there's the big women's rights march
that it's gonna be like a Handmaid's
Tale he's going to remove your right to
choose and just just grab your your
your uterus and tear it out like
sub-zero and Mortal Kombat that's what
they want you don't think because why
simple things like reversing the
reversal of mexico city policy where
American dollars shouldn't be funding
abortions overseas maybe perhaps
defunding Planned Parenthood they want
you to believe this it's going to be
tyrannical rule that women are
second-class citizens but the truth is
women in North Korea are treated far
more horribly than you could ever
imagine Donald Trump to do women they're
deprived of education job opportunities
that of course objected to violence at
home and oh not to mention the forced
abortions in labor camps Donald Trump
wants to stop funding abortions they
kind of go another direction anybody who
makes any kinds of claims like this has
obviously not done any research at all
no homework they're not making this
claim right now they won't make this
they won't draw this comparison because
they'll realize how stupid they sound
but if you just go through the time line
and you look at their claims on Donald
Trump versus their treatment of North
Korea I think that's why so many people
are bothered by it instead you just get
a bunch of folks on Twitter going oh you
suck no no let's look at the timeline
let's commit like Dinesh D'Souza said is
the law applied equally is the standard
applied equally I would say make like
their claim that Donald Trump is a
tyrant who of course wants to do away
with freedom of the press how often have
we heard this you've heard it from
nearly everybody he wants to do away
with the press and maybe some truth
there because he talked about fake news
and sometimes gets a little overzealous
but the truth is there is no freedom of
press in North Korea the press is
government-run and listening to
unauthorized foreign broadcasts or
possessing dissident publications are
considered crimes against the state
there's potentially a death penalty
involved North Korea always say
potentially we mean absolutely a claim
America from Adam Arnett America is this
an imperialist country yeah this is
something I always find funny they talk
about it so we can't spend so much money
overseas this nation-building it's it's
expensive this evil empire being an
impact it's not expensive its profitable
an empire is just taking stuff it's kind
of Empire 101 101 anybody split plate
command & Conquer it's why you don't
conquer countries I don't have anything
to take yeah it's not worth the effort a
shin building is costly America is the
first anti Empire so comparing this
whole idea of an imperialist United
States again
people protest and boycott simple events
whether it's a pastor speaking or Donald
Trump speaking and they march in the
streets so if you're going to apply it
equal you can't give praise to North
Korea for anything despite how nice of
Christmas lights they put on their fake
villages Lester Holt if you look at a
map of countries that the United says
had a military presence in at one time
or another if we were an impact we
effectively rule half the world if we
permanently invaded just take their
stuff you talk about dropping news we
dropped pamphlets trying to warn
Japanese citizens of the bombings and I
know some people saying well maybe we
didn't maybe drop them in the wrong
towns guess what I don't think we need
to drop pamphlets at all I think you
dropped the a-bomb because these guys
were total and complete Tolls hell-bent
on killing anyone who didn't share the
same amount of vowels in their last name
and by the way it was used to save four
more lives than it would have taken in a
land [ __ ] and Japan didn't pick up the
bill for Kinkos either North Korea on
the other hand the Human Rights Watch
reports that Kim jong-un's regime now
they have the prison camps where
starvation obviously is common they
endure sexual assault torture by gods
Garen grabs guards often ending up in
public execution the UN officials
estimate that between 80,000 120,000
people are imprisoned in political
prison camp now now I don't mean like
someone here saying like black people
are political prisoners no no I mean
they're actually political dissidents
being forced having forced abortions
being raped in prison by guards and then
publicly executed yeah okay not only is
Kim jong-un assassinated tons of
government officials in of course
political dissidence he said many of his
own family members killed these were 340
people executed for personal and
political reasons right so here's
something that's just so funny when we
talk about the United States being an
evil empire um could you imagine if kim
jeong-hoon were President of the United
States of America think about this right
they just want nukes right and there's
always threatening Japan and South Korea
so here's the greatest case against
United States begin evil empire we have
Canada this country rich in natural
resources yeah there is nothing and I'm
Canadian
there is nothing they could do to stop
us Kim jong-eun has no capabilities and
he's threatening South Korea and Japan
and the United States every now and then
which is adorable but if you had the
ability you can bet he'd start some crap
imagine if you were president of a
country like the United States I'm not
Donald Trump
shun-kun Canada would be gone by
tomorrow noon and he would take their
stuff Trudeau wouldn't stand a chance
and I don't understand this what does it
take for people in the press to
absolutely hate and despise one we use
as we talk about it everyone I disagree
with this Hitler right we don't want to
do that I think there's a legitimate
comparison to be made here between kim
jeong-hoon
and hitler this is someone who kills
political dissidents this is someone who
obviously believes in his superiority
this is an evil evil human being and we
look back and say oh never again if you
look at the Olympics why why are we okay
with effectively little Hitler or little
Hitler's Liaisons walking into the
Olympics and talking about what how nice
their dresses are and how good they can
flap on cue what does it take for you to
say hey no no no no no get the hell out
you're not welcome here
why why because you're part of the
regime from little Hitler you start
telling people you can come to the game
it's a perfectly legitimate comparison
he's just not very effective no he said
he's effectively just Shortbus Hitler
[Laughter]
Mann is a talent can't take that away
from American leftist news outlets are
busy celebrating North Korea at the
Olympics okay and of course couldn't
well simultaneously condemning Donald
Trump because he said it he tweeted
something mean let's not let them forget
otto warmbier the 22-year old college
student at north korea arrested for
taking down a poster he went into a coma
remember a North Korean prison and you
never woke up but that didn't stop
Politico from tweeting this this is
where the Fred warmbier criticizes North
Korean Olympic spirit talking about the
dad critic the the dad whose son was
killed by this evil regime and you said
he's they're criticizing their Olympic
spirit where's your Christmas spirit
this headline should read father hates
evil regime who we are simultaneously
praising because we're pieces of [ __ ]
that's what that headline should read
and I just find this so crazy this is
what we talked abut I want to hear from
you what you think if if you can
separate the art from
artists you know like Sean Penn's an
idiot but you know what he was good and
I am sandy played one hell of a [ __ ]
can you do that while you're separating
evil Hitler regime sending out people to
clap do you separate the art from the
artist but I find it funny with the left
is victim culture they're constantly
looking for victims to prop them up so
much so that Shaun King had a career in
faking it they are so busy looking for
victims with this victim culture all the
time people who they can pit against
each other but they ignore whether yeah
you have an actual victim here to wonder
grant a father whose son was put into a
coma and murdered from an evil regime I
would say that's a victim here you go
left you're always looking for victims
here's the dad of a kid who was killed
by Shortbus Hitler he seems to be
criticizing their Olympic spirit what
hey did you enjoy this video here's the
thing you wrote you're here this is the
end of this oh we don't care because you
already watched it but if you really
didn't like it and you want to justify
it leave a comment below telling us why
you didn't like the video and if you
liked us let us know and subscribe to
the channel because that lets the
overlords at YouTube know that you know
what you're alright